[Music]
[Music]
okay everybody I am joined today by Rhea
seehorn aka Kim Wexler from better call
Saul ray how are you today I'm great
I am excellent so first off it's just a
dream of mine to be talking to you so
this is an interview I'm really
especially excited to do and I have a
lot of questions I just want to kind of
like shoot your way that I've been dying
to ask you for five seasons but I
actually wanted to start off with the
end of last season where it ends on the
iconic shot of Kim in shock of this song
character in front of her now you know
as Ray and we as the audience know where
it ends up with Saul but how do you get
to the part of Kim that's not knowing
that and that you can sell that to us as
an audience that you don't have a clue
of where this is going how do you get to
that as an actress or that I don't know
where the fall class or ends up where
the ball character in-depth ends up yeah
you know that is something that I have
to consciously remind myself of quite a
bit because it'll even come up in
channel discussions and stuff you know
where we discuss the show its fans and
critics and stuff and they will
sometimes be curious about how Kim if
someone as intelligent as Kim could ever
be involved with and though speak of the
person that basically under Britton bad
and I don't like that I myself can have
nothing thank you Bob so one of the
genius elements of the show that the
throat and cuticle have always put in
there certainly it's the origin story of
Saul Goodman in ha-joon ago became Saul
but there's also a lot of other
characters both of them myself included
that you're also watching these sort of
incremental steps at a time it isn't
about would this would this character go
eight and read the question is where
this character go A to B and then B to C
and unseated B so I try to take the
scripts on the moment and the scenes on
for what they are presently
and that being said and the blast even
still was this sort of much larger step
and for Tim I think that it is just as
if not more so disorienting that he has
done it without but she thought they
were doing the stand for quote unquote
the better which is those film making
the bar something that he is the raft
about his brother and you know really is
repentant in all of this because I think
Tim believed he should be practicing who
does deserve a draw a license and is
inherently a good person if they could
just see the other sides of him and we
at the audience often see him through
him guys to see that there are redeeming
qualities about him and his intentions
are often morally ethically correct it's
just big messages I'm not although we're
crossing over into other territories out
to be consult yeah I think that in that
moment she thought she was helping them
unfortunately the biggest blow to her is
that she's in there before she became
emotional about it and she wasn't
running on the film right so when we see
now in Episode one of season five when
Kim is like we're first seeing her kind
of in action with this Saul Goodman
character and Kim is with her clients at
a bench and she knows she's kind of like
in a tight spot here but Saul comes
through and suggests them to do a
performance to get what would work and
you could see during the scene that Kim
is like Jimmy calm down and constantly
still calling him Jimmy and saying Jimmy
stop and at the staircase right after
Kim to herself kind of like freaks out
now this is one of those scenes where
there's so many layers to Saul what
would you say where were you at at Kim's
mind set in that scene what is she
thinking at that moment and of course
the brilliant Peter Gould wrote it and
Bronwyn who directed it was really
wonderful to play that idea that he's
really testing the idea that we're gonna
have a say in last season and use our
powers for good and she is playing a
very dangerous game of when it is okay
to call out to other lines and women is
not and in this moment it would be for
the better
if this young man didn't go to trial and
can can see that and she knows it but it
is also unethical and against the bar to
lie to your client but I must make the
decision anytime so it was really
wonderful to play that struggle because
it really goes to the heart of the game
she's been playing with herself in the
end she does it's in his way and I think
it is really hard for her as an outfit
we played that soon in the stairwell
quite a few different ways trying it out
is it sickening temper is it infuriating
to her is she angry at herself or angry
at Jimmy um or both because we have
prior to now we mostly see her get
excited when she pulls off some kind of
mini scale or something with him and
then you'll see the guilt later but in
this one she is immediately really
bothered by it and for me I played it as
a very disorienting thing that I know I
have to get down this stairwell and then
you to look like I I pulled him I'm
gonna go speak to the judge and I'm line
and I'm gonna go to the stairwell and my
disciple had like a wire in a little
dark corner for five minutes before I
can come back and it's very lonely and I
think she feels extremely conflicted
about who she is
at this moment in time and to me it kind
of left the anger was with Jimmy the
Ratana Texas farewell I think it was
much more confident in herself I said ah
she feels about herself at this point in
her life who she appreciates now who she
was before Milan who she's becoming it's
interesting how you say that - were you
know Kim is such a self-aware character
and has all these deep thoughts are
saying and looking at herself so I feel
like in Episode two now when we see her
with Jimmy and Jimmy showing her this
house he wants to get them and there's
kind of like this shocked look on Kim's
face and it kind of starts progressing
the story of now where's you know Kim
and Saul's relationship going to be or
Kim and Jimmy per se so there's a line K
actually says in that C
when you're looking at the house where
Kim says oh it's the closet of your
dreams and then Jimmy says our dreams
kisses back sure I that likes me so I
want to know when you were doing that
scene with Jimmy going through that
house and that tour where was Kim's head
at there specifically and with their
kind of relationship and where she's
thinking about it those are really fun
to issue and I'm Alison Tatlock wrote
that and Norberto Barbra directed and we
had a really good time mapping out this
little mini journey that happens in that
house she's still upset and angry with
Jimmy for what happened in the courtroom
that we were just talking about in
episode one she's more as I said she's
more upset at herself and so it's
important to her to have these
boundaries it's interesting that you say
she's so self-aware she's incredibly
self-aware and but she also
compartmentalized to a fault
in a way that she purposely blinds
herself sometimes in my opinion and
excused the way she looks at something
to benefit the outcome she wants and
that includes how she looks at herself
and I think a lot of us do that but when
we're watching a character like Kim and
I've been so grateful to fans of the
show and fans of my character they
really see her as a 3-dimensional real
person and often see their perspective
through through her so it's fun it's it
is fun playing that to know that
somebody is as you said that intelligent
that self-aware and yet has these blind
spots that for the most part I think she
creates herself and while she's in this
house she lays down boundaries for Jimmy
I was like we're not I'm not lying to my
clients and you got to stay out of my
business and then you see you see the
these seeds of what they've always had
this witty repartee back and forth and
it's a knowing kind of comedy that they
share with each other I know who the
real you is and you know who the real me
is and we dance around it a little bit
but it's actually the safest both of us
feel at least I can speak for Kim and
she can speak for Bob and how he plays
Jimmy but I feel like except when you
start to get back to that place
and she sang stuff about his closet
because it is a very funny nod to the
fact that Kim has noticed that the
closet at home keeps expanding with
color clothing and you know he's
starting to dress differently and I
think it's you know but they don't they
don't hit you over the head with that
Kim isn't just like wow you have started
to wear you know bright citrus colors
together because I don't actually think
she's much of a fashion and one of the
things I love about her is she just does
she doesn't let people be who they are
and I think she just sort of bears
witness and it's like huh that's
interesting so the fact that the only
comment she's making is don't pretend
like I'm the person with a bunch of
clothes you're the person with a such
colossal I think it's very funny and
very clever in that moment so I guess so
what I'm trying to get is am I looking
to deepen the whole scene in the sense
where like it ends where Jimmy just
seems so excited about them finally
having a house and you're like kind of
like we'll see is there a reason why Kim
so like not back to him like yeah I
can't wait to get a house one day I
think she has some awareness that that
the larger symbolic and metaphorical as
opposed to Jimmy thinking we should buy
this exact house today he's asking her
to in my opinion he's asking her to
trust the future he is going to build as
Saul Goodman and again she hasn't seen
Breaking Bad so the solvent man she
knows he let her know that he sells
phones don't like phones in a parking
lot and wants to do crazy discount deals
and we saw I think I think season three
she see the commercial that he made and
I think she sees more she than four I
can't keep track but so he's a he's he's
humorous with some sort of dangerous
edge there's something sloppy about him
there's something I think it concerns
Kim that it is beneath his potential and
not in a knobby way but based on what
Jimmy said he wanted in life there was a
time where he wanted a seat at the big
kids table and couldn't understand why
places at HHM kept keeping him out of
the club and he has not talked to her
about this shift in how he sees his own
potential
now so I don't find chem judgy at all
except for like I said she's bearing
witness of like oh you said you wanted
to go here and you're now taking this
really circuitous route that's not going
to result in what you said you wanted
and but here's Jimmy showing her a very
expensive house and you do see her haves
just small moments where she's able to
smile and and dream about is it possible
they could have a future is is there a
way for them to compartmentalize their
relationship in the same way that she
wanted them to compartmentalize their
business can do it his way and I do it
my way if we could still have people we
could still have the shady side of the
law and the district court judges over
for cheese and crackers on a Friday
because that world work and she's
letting herself dream about it for just
for just a minute and he's selling her
and she's saying instead of no she's
saying maybe and so and he knows and
then Jimmy knows in that scene that it
it's him to come get her we all have
those moments in the relationship where
you know which one of you is supposed to
go after the other one he knows that so
that's why he's all positive and he's a
Salesman in that moment on and I think
her baby is actually a lot it's a lot
for her today
okay yeah and I think that's like what
you're saying to about could this work
and this two different sides of the
spectrum here live together in the
future and it's like I guess it makes it
such a tragic scene in a way because we
know because this is a prequel that
doesn't end up that way and it kind of
shows you like what could have Bryce
especially where they have the two sinks
together and there's always those flirty
moments between you guys even with like
the shower and stuff so yeah that's yeah
that was just brilliant scene to me and
what I wanted to get to too is then Kim
is such a mysterious character and I
think that's what makes her so
interesting what I mean what I mean by
mysterious is just we don't really ever
get an inkling about her backstory and
without spoiling anything I think in
Episode three we started get a little
hint at it but for you as an actress
playing Kim some actors you know they
make a whole backstory in a journal and
make where they think this person kind
of came from have you done that for Kim
do you have in your head like what her
possible upbringing was and
her life story I did I didn't um I leave
space for there to be growth because one
of the most fun things for an actor on
the show is that they don't make their
characters in movable objects that you
grow and change you're actually affected
by things so the can we see now is very
different than we saw in the pilot in an
organic human being way not like to make
sure you know what I mean they're not
tricks really like you see these
characters evolve both intrinsically and
extrinsic ly some of the things that are
happening and with Kym
I did have a backstory I I collect more
information as we go it's sort of like a
jigsaw puzzle that's constantly
unfinished okay I don't want to make the
whole picture too clear because I want
to leave room for other pieces but there
are definitely things I thought from the
pilot episode that have never there was
never anything that happened that made
me think oh I bet that's not true ideas
of where she came from how she was
raised what she left behind when she
decided to leave somewhere and come
which she refuses to tell anybody
exactly what species from and and come
to a mail room like at an age same as
Ginni I mean to move to Albuquerque and
start over in the mail room at HHM I
always thought you're either running to
something or running away from something
if you're starting over on that level
when you're not you know a high school
intern high school graduate intern so
what's going on there and her addiction
/ repulsion of sort of scams and
coloring outside of the lines there
seems to be a familiarity there and I
don't know what from so I I have my
ideas and I was really excited they
guided to explore some of that this
season as well that's awesome and uh
yeah that that leads me to to another
kind of more going into the head of Kim
Wexler is how much of Rhea seehorn
is in the character of Kim Wexler I wish
I was more like um every season when we
go back and we start I have to spend two
days before my first thing of shooting
just basically sitting
my hands just reminding myself to be
still she's so much more still than I am
sure and I find many of her
characteristics enviable if not noble
she doesn't care about filling silences
I mean gee just to have that superpower
would not care about awkward pauses in
the room she just lets people hang
themselves if their being in it she
doesn't she doesn't care to make this
any easier and yet she's not did not
mean she just isn't um it's funny she's
such a fixer but not in social
circumstances and I'm the other way like
I always have to fix everything but uh I
guess that part I very much understand
exam I completely understand the idea of
when things are crazy my salvation from
it is thinking that if I put my head
down and just work hard enough I'll be
okay but everything will be okay if I
can if I pick myself up by my own
bootstraps and put my nose down and keep
working and I do understand that in Kim
and it's it's a risky way to look at
things because of course it's not true
and it's it's actually a control issue
but I understand why that feels safer
and I have also just that to sort of by
by deduction that also tells me
something about her backstory her need
to always make sure she can keep herself
stable well at least try and be able to
take care of herself in any situation
and be self-sufficient is kind of
extreme and so by deductive math that is
something that I've always used to say
like what did you what did you come from
if you need that then it usually is the
opposite interesting so when you're
talking about also getting into a
character two days earlier do you put
your hair in a ponytail is there any
part of method um getting into hair and
makeup is it is it is big for me as well
as wearing the suit I'm very aware
physically when the few scenes when I
have my hair down or I'm not in a suit
and Jennifer Bryan is brilliant with the
costumes and Trish Almeida created and
designed that ponytail that people like
Jennifer Bell helped us with it last
season and sherry moneth ah no that's
the makeup and all of these people are
heavily involved with and then Peter
weighs in as well
so yes I am a once my hair is in the
ponytail it isn't sort of like you know
the character appears because I have a
funny telling but there is something
it's actually I'm more aware of Kim when
she literally and figuratively lets her
hair down it is very seldom and
sometimes her hair is even back but it's
a lower ponytail and it's looser and
she's usually only that way with Jimmy
except when she broke her arm and there
were whole discussions about what what
is she capable of and we came up with
the barrette and this sort of low-slung
thing but that's a word that she has a
mask
she had the master versus Jimmy does
okay because I said that's amazing
that's how layers and like specific to
detail the show is that now I'm going to
be looking at the angle of your ponytail
every scene to see what it's telling us
oh yeah no it's it's definitely
something that's talked about and
decided as is from the beginning with
Jennifer Brian and Trish we thought
about the working women that we all grew
up was that were trying very hard to get
a foothold in middle class which is its
own struggle and many of people I think
find that accessible right now in the
world and none of those women I know
change their hairstyles their purse or
her jewelry ever they don't have time
for that crap yeah everything had to be
extremely practical and in in season one
Jennifer Bryan even did stuff that the
audience wouldn't even see which is my
suits are they're off blue or off black
they don't match we decided that she
probably still has to go to Marshall
nothing wrong with Marshalls but she's
trying to get she has separates she has
two jackets and three skirts that she
keeps switching around and they weren't
tailored they we made them fit like they
said like she you bought off the rack
and then as it has progressed and she
make or money the fit has changed but
she still we repeat tops and bottoms and
all that and shoes and the jewelry does
not change
and so it was all born of a practical
thing and also just trying to honor
people who really do work their asses
off trying to pull themselves up out of
something yeah yeah that's really
awesome and it shows in the work that
how much effort all these departments
and yourself do for this character of
Kim it's really a spectacle to watch the
last question I had for you Ray is
someone tweeted one day to you an idea
of you playing Debbie Harry in a blondie
biopic and I was like oh would you do it
and what is your favorite blondie song
Oh probably I mean I love love I'm
probably harder class that's a great one
yeah I would totally do that it's
literally like when I saw that tree toes
like oh my god that is literally like
the perfect match and uh that goes to
what I want to say at the end of this
interview is that we need as the
audience to support you and that is a
petition for Rhea seehorn to get blondie
to get an Emmy that's way over dough and
to please make make a Funko pop of Kim
Wexler all these things need to happen
and they will happen I believe but
that's very kind of it thank you so much
ray for joining me it's really an honor
and when I started out doing interviews
on this show when I started covering
season one I saw it was one of my dreams
that one day I get to talk to you and
it's happening so this is still a pinch
me moment so I'm really grateful for it
and grateful for you doing it oh that's
so nice of you thank you very much is
there anything you want to promote
besides better call Saul or that we've
looked forward to I just shot an amazing
film in upstate New York I saw that you
had think I mean yes
yeah that's to be coming out on Netflix
it's such a great story based on the
book when all things used to appear
James Norton and Amanda Siegfried are
the leads and they're both so wonderful
Shari Springer Berman and Bob Cole
Cheney director that I'm really excited
it's a psychological thriller and we had
so much fun doing it you know like
there's something else I'm forgetting
there was a
on IMDB that correct me if I'm wrong but
there's a phone you're going to be and
directed by the lovely Giuliana Murray
is this true uh works we're trying to
make that happen well great
yeah yeah and I'm gonna do she's
directing us a reading of a new play as
well that I'm gonna do next weekend
awesome yeah she's a lot of fun and I'm
finishing my directing my second short I
hope to put out and put in festivals and
doing a lot of fun boys sever work I
play a really fun character in the show
that I don't think I'm allowed to say
yeah oh yeah it shows coming out and
another I'm long-form a long-form
podcast serialized narrative thing
that's I'm really fun where I play a
detective and I'm executive producing
and playing the lead in that that's
amazing I cannot wait everyone
please check out better call Saul every
Monday night at 9 p.m. on AMC as the
season progresses after that awesome
first and second episode much more to
come ray thank you so much and have a
great day and I hope to talk to you four
spaces